I hate that I'm tinder when they [ __ ]
do that already
what do you well everybody to my dumb
friends yes again I hate like I
understand I'm already used to on tinder
when they have the the first picture
this is like you should be outside of a
car dealership in Tulsa right now you
know what's the weird thing there's only
like seven people watching the streaming
show so you're doing physical comedy for
77 people and some of the people that
will actually look like you great thanks
man
let me go find its before I mean one day
Sunday's kind of like Sundays or
whatever day but you got a lady already
hooked on a rough weekend uh what do you
this weekend those two I flew to Denver
to go see economy what concert The
Flaming Lips Oh MSG great concert
they're great man yeah we they played at
Madison Square Garden yeah with the will
code New Year's Eve Wow how long ago was
that
Oh 2004 whoa amazing really show yeah no
I've seen them like a dozen times and
they were playing at Red Rocks with the
Denver symphysis symphony or got such a
cool [ __ ] concert yeah and they were
just doing the soft bulletin which is
one of my favorite albums of theirs
mm-hmm so flu there went to the show
flew back Friday night and then did two
shows last night then just yeah just
kind of had drinks Thursday Friday and
Saturday so it's like and did Brendon
small and Steve Agee do that music show
baked oh it's like you do a stand-up set
and then you do a song with the band Oh
night so uh yeah my throat's just shot I
was seeing and saying Lita Ford song
which one
ain't no big thing you don't know that
song damn for a second I thought that
was what's going on no no no that's four
Non Blondes this is Laurie guys I'm
sorry from a different generation bring
it up yeah I have it and I was listening
to it all day it's such that's like from
when I was a kid the lyrics are so
stupid yeah it's 88 yeah I've never I've
never heard this it's catchy man it
definitely had that instrumentals of
like a montage in a mall yeah yeah
workout montage she was the lead
guitarist for The Runaways yeah yeah
that's where she got started and then
she went solo in the early eighties how
did the eighties make so many cool
people become corny if you don't saying
like like the George Harrison albums in
the eighties are like family bad I'm
wrong but no but but wait afford it's
like The Runaways is a cool it's like
still a cool band yeah so but then
you're leading forward and you're like
doing the corniest thing that song is
like I mean that was just that's the
kind of music that was going on then
that was like the 88 was like the peak
of hair metal yeah what was the thing
that was like hair metal pop I just
thought a bit of Runaways isn't there
like the whole thing where there's
Japanese pop bands like they're
encouraged to be virgins for a long time
oh no that's a different thing that the
whole yeah anything that I heard a
podcast about that they talked about I
forget now I find out that they have
significant other like boyfriends and
girlfriends
the fans revolt and they lose their [ __ ]
and they just like start yet they lose
their minds and then they found out one
girl had sex and then they have certain
colors for each act and then when the
girl came out usually it's like they all
have these light at their phone so they
have these light-up things I'd like
they'll all be blue for one guy to all
be green for another girl they'll be and
this one girl who found out she had sex
and when she came out everybody turned
their lights off no my name is just a
pitch-black Stadium and something crazy
like that where it's like really [ __ ]
up that is a repressed culture yeah
they're also like and that's kind of
like the codes you know like how gay
guys have codes where they hang
different colored handkerchiefs out of
their back pockets is this like I feel
like this is how deep throat used to
[ __ ] in the seventies it's from the
Nixon informant okay Japanese culture
like they do weird [ __ ] too lowly piss
and [ __ ] yeah I don't think that there's
a way I mean there's one really cool
thing I found out about a work which is
I guess there's a non-profit in Japan
called white hands or something like
that or some which is like women who
give like hand jobs to like really
handicapped people or really like
terminally ill that's nice people Wow
yeah it's a great service I mean think
about how many what that's not sure I
don't know I don't know I really don't
know how you can connect that but I feel
like you know if some of those guys had
come a little bit maybe there would be
less shootings mass shooter yeah maybe
maybe I'm I'm oversimplifying the
problem but I mean I think yeah they'll
do it if you're [ __ ] if they're crazy
[ __ ] nerd you're gonna you're gonna
lose it anyway like I mean cuz then if
they start getting these hand jobs then
they'll fall in love with the girl and
try to pursue a
you know more of a relationship with
them and then when the rejected buyer
then they're still gonna go she they're
still gonna do it at the end of her
first probably yeah the end goal is
still that's what we should do is get
suicidal girls to do the hand jobs for
the potential mass shooters so that way
if it goes wrong like everybody wins
like they don't unload at a mall they
just kill a girl it was it may be
probably gonna kill herself Brendon
Walsh depressing problem solving like
why - all problems man and it's like
Elliott Smith life hacks are things
going with your girlfriend good man we
just just went and saw that concert
we've guys many other Roy here now like
a year yeah a little bit more well it
was like a slow burn you know like it
when it started off I mean I don't know
where she was that but I thought this
isn't gonna last very long like I just
thought it was gonna be a casual kind of
thing yeah but then the more we hung out
we were like oh yeah you know realize
that we like each other I think it's
like the best way somebody can start out
no I love for two seconds and Dan's
asking you about your relationship next
guest by telling him to cut now he's
gonna wait here for half-hour
he's company you're already [ __ ] up
the schedule and then you come in
[ __ ] on me I'm just saying guys do
this Shawn's the king of this like he'll
give you a barber then you'll get a
[ __ ] problem you guys hang out yeah
we hang out too much we don't we live on
the other side we gotta call Wes I think
that that's the guy call us solution
well be wait cuz that it was actually
that you're right it's a good point
because we talk on the phone so much mmm
that when I saw him at UCB for the other
times the other day and it wasn't like
that when I saw you I gave you a hug
like hey haven't seen you in a while we
don't even do that because we feel like
we just saw you really didn't even move
Randy spent too much time together
before and we're next to each other in
the same building Noble I don't know
really I mean they'll be a little kind
of like I'll just get on each other's
nerves but I think it's like a parent
and then it's like all right we're not
then we just don't hang out for a few
days yeah you're adults yeah yeah I
think that's good yeah but nothing I
guess ride this guy home after this
ending yeah it's embarrassing me I mean
him and his girlfriend split up they
were together for like seven yeah he was
telling me about then yeah and they but
they were living together so when it was
like when they split up it's like well
you have to move you got to get out of
the [ __ ] house you can't linger
around no no way and he was looking for
places and and there was a place
available in my building I was like well
there's a there's an apartment from
Randy's like is that a good idea I was
like I don't know I didn't want to be
like you can move anywhere except for
this one available we'll see how it goes
and actually it's fine you know it's
kind of know like we have keys to each
other's place so like when one of us is
out of town we can [ __ ] yeah or
whatever that's good yeah that's perfect
I've got a friend now who wanted to live
next to me friend from high school and
I'm like I don't think that's a good
idea yeah it's like why am I cuz I get
annoyed at you now and I see you only
like yes yeah there's no I don't think
we can live together now we used to live
together and we could now there's one
guy this guy this is the same guy who
[ __ ] like like two days ago he just
had noise me don't know and he's like
hey listen man can you help me out here
woman I was his name
but Alex he calls me up and he's like
hey man um can you help me out I cuz he
used to live in LA my drawer I forgot my
dry-cleaning and I'm like yeah I guess
I'm picking up he goes yeah I left it uh
I left it two years ago get rid of it I
thought after a year well they called
him I'm gonna worry we're gonna get rid
of it and then I'm like all right man
I'll go pick it up and then he goes okay
cool and then can you tell me what time
you're gonna pick it up Mike
[ __ ] been there
two years it's been there two years it's
fine
an hour's not gonna kill this [ __ ]
Armenian family or was the [ __ ] sold was
he away he was in New York so now I got
old [ __ ] dry cleaning in my bar I saw
that that's here that's holy [ __ ] some
of it's like [ __ ] Nepalese blankets
and shitty God or stuff he got from
Bhutan it's a ton of [ __ ] I made fun of
them I thought it was his no it's all my
writing well I didn't even address
because you said it I'm like yep I got
it I knew what you were and I was like I
did anyone have was it made me angry
that's [ __ ] all my friends annoy me I
have a plant that's pretty good thing
maybe chew everything that well I know
that drugs yeah weird dancing cheers try
to get a literary with it anyway no but
that's what happens you can't spend any
much time with anybody that's like kind
of ghost your yeah we're talking about
like last week with marriage two weeks
ago I feel like we're actually getting
worse at doing this podcast I know whose
fault was that you didn't do the
scheduling right no that's not true I
did it it got [ __ ] up Danny first up
now enough Dan Danny Solomon's here hi
Danny
very funny guy Danny and Shawn wrote a
script together that's true you'll find
out about that next week man but no but
basically that's right who's their minds
we can I know week all right guy right
and he works at a car wash but he also
is in clean getaway
it seems like I'm Mike Epps vehicle I
have an idea that since this hopefully
I'll execute it before I've had a rash
of ideas being stolen from me well to
have you really yeah there's one I don't
to talk about it I will talk about it
afterwards but there's one an idea that
I pitched around for two years and now
it's a slightly tweaked version of it is
on a [ __ ] do you think it's like
literally it was stolen from you a like
it's like the all the key elements like
all the entire essence of the thing is
they're down to like the name okay it's
slightly different and I'm like you know
I pitched this and talked about it so
much for the past two years somebody's
working for this show that was like you
know okay he's not doing anything with
this idea yeah and or they just pitched
as their own and we're like hey I have
this idea and I think it's I don't know
I just I just learned about it but
apparently it's been going on for a
little bit oh sure
and it really bummed me out fresh off
the boat it was like a family of white
people moved into like a restaurant it's
actually it's not on one episode there's
an Asian person but that one that one
really stung because it's happened in
the past where I'm like yeah maybe or
maybe it's parallel thinking but it's
like you know you see an idea where like
[ __ ] I've been wanting you you know I've
had an ID like that yeah and this one
stung because it's like I still thought
something was gonna happen with it like
it was a little bit of a complicated
idea which is why it fell through with
the two places that I that wanted to do
it mm-hmm but it I'm and then there's
this other little thing that I'm like
that was inspired by something that I've
been doing and I'm not a psycho who
thinks everybody's like - pretty pretty
close that's a pretty good gut when I'm
like I can picture that opening this to
themselves
yeah yeah like one of my really really
good friends tweeted something that was
is a joke that I've done before and I
know that he didn't purposely steal
because it's not like that it's not a
joke I use all the time but I know I've
said it in tweeds and no me no no no no
he wasn't how you're telling me that I
know I know he wasn't stealing it but I
said like hey man I think I did this
yeah how do you want me to delete it and
I'm like no cuz you know I'm just
probably gonna do it again yeah I'll
tell them like I'll probably just do it
again and we could just it'll do it like
if the Milton Berle's or it's still
funny Reverend I was like tweet
something that I've tweeted like a year
prior like the Santa my goal with its
original thought and I'm like oh I'm
pretty sure I've tweeted that before oh
I've gotten off stage and did a bit I
thought it was brilliant for the first
time and being oh I just ripped that off
of John Wayne remember that when were
cows open mic in New York City oh the
worst open my camera you know Danny do
you want to sit down you want to come in
for this all right Brennan you know your
thunder you still that Walsh thunder
what yeah but that's a good starting
point sure Danny
Salomon we all came up together in New
York City comedy but there's a horrible
open mic called the limerick house the
Limerick house was this place it was a I
was Irish bar yeah and it was a brutal I
have a good story about that place it
was so bad you remember it right Danny
used to all the time right I don't know
people need to know that people need to
hear that again yes there I was there
when I found out Michael Jackson died I
was there for a show once this is my
story of it where Tim not Tim Warner egg
wasn't do comedy no bed Mari
what's a Nintendo DS he there was a
there was a group of a group of flying
guys there that we're heckling the the
end and we talked about this on the
podcast
oh no go ahead I don't think so good
they were heckling ed while he was up
there and Ed literally got so mad at
them he unzipped his pants pulled his
whole dick out pulled his dick out in
his balls and put but like didn't pull
it out where you could see it
pulled it out so it was in his hand and
then just shook his hand with it in it
at and their handler was like what are
you doing because I think they're a Book
of Mormon and Mormon so shitty political
but it was it was pretty funny
it was pretty nuts that was what Brennan
have you ever pitched something where a
middle of the pitch you're like this
couldn't be going any worse right now
yeah I think I've pretty much had good
experiences yeah I mostly have too but
they're think of the I can't remember
the specifics but I remember just kind
of being like let's just go not like why
are we wasting yeah yeah yeah I remember
one time I just got yeah you can just
tell like I was pitching something with
Jamie Lee and I watched the woman we
were pitching to admire the foliage in
the window we watched her like take
account of the whole tree it was a
nightmare I did a general meeting the
other day where the woman asked me to do
a stand-up joke at the meeting she's
like well could you do that could you do
a stand-up could you do a joke for me
right now and I go no I can't I can't do
that you don't have like a go to just
one now and [ __ ] you she's like a
classic Dice Clay joke
smoking I was so taken aback I'm like no
[ __ ] you I'm not doing that
gotta do with this a man yeah an smokey
dish I remember I did one was really bad
new is it was two people I'd sold some
for it I was the reason it sucked that
pitch and then at the end of it I
literally just went alright sounds good
and then I left and then I was pinching
it with his other writer who's really
good I was like yeah that was that was
not never had that book and I don't
think that was I mean I don't know of
our relationships repaired since when we
cuz I was so bad during that bad well
you know it's so scary is like I've done
one a pitch that's gone like okay there
probably went really bad and I didn't
realize I haven't pitched that many
times but the worst thing ever is when
you're pitching over that
videoconferencing thing yes yeah you
make a joke in the room and everybody
the room kind of laughs or whatever and
then you see people in the video they're
like from New York and the deal from LA
that we're videoconferencing n gotta be
out here but your comedy instinct is
when there's silence for even one second
you're like well you better fill it with
another and then all of a sudden you're
backed up to jokes deep in when they
finally respond to me exactly I remember
Mike I mean Mike Mike Drucker is a
writer on The Tonight Show we were
pitching something to this reality
Brenda it was like the first pitch I
ever did this is reality production
company and we came in in suits like
holding dossiers push the file towards
them it was a really professional but it
was not right for like my offer is this
senator genius it's just one of those
things where it's just an awkward
situation no matter how you cut it's
like an audition auditions all of the
most awkward thing I just had a
revelation the other day that uh if
you're I'm like I shouldn't still like
this is a sign that things just didn't
work out I shouldn't be auditioning
at this age well you had an audition
that yeah I had an audition the other
day and was like what am I [ __ ] do
this is stupid
I'm not like yeah because I feel like a
lot of the auditions that I get to is
when they just cast a [ __ ] wide net
where it's like okay we already saw the
people we thought would be right for it
we're not finding the right person so
just whoever you have yeah yeah because
you're there it's like there's no rhyme
or reason it's like like sometimes you
go and it's like okay everybody's a
[ __ ] doughy bearded guy right so
that's what they're looking but then
there's other ones like this one and I
went to the other day where it's like oh
everybody I know is there just like I
had what you got one like that where I
should have for a commercial but I was
like I was wishing for the same
commercialize wee-bey from the wire we
were playing for the same exact way
we're looking for a Cheri Oteri Hannibal
Buress but you really do know says this
but you do get an idea of what they
think you look like the minute you walk
in there an old joke but it's true you
well can you like wolf I got a [ __ ] I
started going to a train I've been
gaining weight over the past two years
trying trying trying to I got it yeah
that's disgusting
I got this the same thing I just bought
like an elliptical slash oh yeah
exercise bike but I bought the cheapest
one don't buy the cheap it's a mine was
like 150 bucks and it looks like a time
machine from 1900 you know what I mean
like what they thought a time machine
was gonna look like back then yeah and
then I use it and it slams up and down
like I'm trying to take flight I have to
I have to do it in my kitchen is the
only place I can put my laptop and I'm
like watching veep bouncing this is fun
having fun so it's not solid to the
ground no not at all looking at my empty
joe auto I don't have those real
high-tech ones where you go online and
you take video classes with somebody
like across the country like you take
SoulCycle classes on your bike at home
that sounds actually I could work ten
grandmother thing yeah yeah but really
you don't want to lose weight right in
casting terms you have to either be
we're pretty fat or pretty good-looking
yeah but where do you know there's too
fat for fat there's but you
aren't close to try and I'm a little bit
fatter than TV fat I think if I was a
little bit lighter to me that's crazy
because I've been I've been watching a
lot of my 600 pound life oh that's
there's a whole event that's real fast
that's TV famine for that yeah I don't
still like that fat gets on TV and it's
[ __ ] good I can't watch that I can't
watch that show i watch two minutes out
Cheryl [ __ ] day there was wonderful
sowed where they cut they did a skin
surgery on someone they always do the
Lap Band first and then when that
finally gets them to a lower weight yeah
at a certain point then they cut off the
excess skin and they actually unfold the
skin like a butterfly piece of chicken
and like showed it in front of but then
but then they blurt out the ladies
nipples that is this isn't a bit but
I've been talking about that for a while
I think that is a [ __ ] craziest thing
like when you watch those plastic
surgeries yeah I was watching one they
were giving a lady a breast implant they
took her nipple off the table to [ __ ]
like commercial there was a trailer I
was watching where it was like it was
again it was one of those TLC if it was
like a fat girl on I like really fat she
was like trying to work out and dance
and then the end of the trailer was just
her bawling hysterically I think and
then the title just goes my big fat
fabulous life tears are just coming down
her big fat face rainy bit we talked
about s for you and he's like is that it
looks like the victim had anal
contusions and he's like that was on TV
at 12 in the well they did Jo I left and
they had Memorial Day like SVU marathon
and then they showed like the one joke
from SVU
hey check it out nobody this is if no
one saw SPU they're like oh is this
gonna be like Burn Notice or watch it
and they're like they found a knife in
the knife that was already in her vagina
they're running out of merit do you guys
all watch like I've never watched any of
those procedurals I watched to watch the
first one otter NYPD Blue I watch my
favorite one was the law no no criminal
intent which is much like the mystery
one okay which wasn't that bad that was
the Vincent everyone that everybody
hated it was off the air in like five
years on the left in five years if
you're a loner you need a few years
thing because dick Wolf's I go for more
like I Forensic Files like I don't like
that real like why am I gonna watch a
fictionalized version of like the real
thing it's ripped from the headlines
they basically take it and then just
make like a person who kind of looks
like an Anna Nicole Smith there's no
like you watch it where it's just a
comedy that's just a comedy it's funny
I'm pretty sure some of the one of the
guys that produced as for you for like a
few years was named speed wheat he was
like the producer / writer / ever one
word is him a Speed Week no no speed
first name okay weed last name and
that's what says had created by written
by speed weed and they were always in
saying you didn't you see the Jonathan
Silverman stand-up comic as for you
where he's the rapist and he works at
the comic strip in New York and he's
like and he's supposed to go to
shock-jock type a comma and they're like
and then they they go like Vincent ice-t
and risk or they go to the college or
just go oh there they go and they watch
him and then they just like he's like
hey Lord or they go because hey
Manhattan Special Victims Unit is here
everybody
and then they arrest him like after the
show like it's like it's like the
dumbest [ __ ] that you're like they have
to be in on it whenever I go to New York
I it seems like I just do like the stand
as as far as clubs go oh yeah
a great club yeah I like it there yeah
and I don't you know there's always
other little sets that pop up and I'm
not like when I go to New York I'm
usually not there for a super long time
and I want to be doing 20 sets a night
so yeah Ann's good to me
the stands are good good place good club
New York comedy clubs great yeah all
chose that book me no rapist no rapists
I would have ABC in a six-episode series
about my Law & Order doll that's still
on right so it's been on for like 20
years but then I found I was like on
tick bull finally doesn't have like
something on but then he just did all
those like Chicago med ones all the
Shire
those are all his counting money all his
wife's name is pussycat e yeah no
forensic file I feel like I've seen all
the Forensic Files now though like cuz
they you haven't seen a new like the
ones that they show in headline news all
right I feel like I've cycled those are
the old ones like they from the 80s or
something or yeah yeah they go up to 81
really mm okay yeah
and then first 48 I'm still on that's if
you want to see if you want to see a
reality show about white people
murdering each other
watch Forensic Files right you're gonna
see a show about black people murdering
each other first and it's always the
same three it's always like like Memphis
and well it's just murdering each other
there's no I played crossover yeah
there's no white on black or black on
white crime on the other show I used to
love first 40 eggs I was like this is
straight-up just there's no like reality
show part to it yeah and I heard it's
not I heard there are like they [ __ ]
with it oh really I'm a friend who was a
camera man and he said it was it I mean
this was years ago yes so crazy about
that Oh Jay show was like I would read
the Vanity Fair recap the next day and
it was like all true it was like no I've
% oh yeah
I had a heart attack yeah you're like oh
he had a blue tie actually in the trial
yeah I was like oh so it was almost
everything was true was crazy holy [ __ ]
one I remember one time this time I
bring things wrong on one episode I was
like wow that's a mostly was just like
what are we like we don't think that
happened at that location but we
definitely know what happened but like
as far as big moves go oh it was all
true or like in putting the smiley face
on a suicide note who put the smile yeah
that was different I don't think he saw
he signed it differently that's crazy or
the dardan and Marcia Clark [ __ ] they
never put that in though but they but we
know that they did show Danny what
[ __ ] was I've never had sex the
weirdest part of that and I still I
didn't finish the oj thing but do you
remember the one episode where they
showed it was during a chase when they
just show like a pizza hut or a Domino's
yeah out of cheese
yeah just to show that like that I think
that night was like the most ordered I
do
yeah right just a weird little insert of
like oh we're gonna make a pizza and a
guy just looks in the bucket and there's
no cheese I still think the funny NBA
Finals to that the funniest one for that
was the funniest blip I don't know
whatever was when I'm in Straight Outta
Compton when Ice Cube is writing a
screenplay this is this is hilarious
people like does it that's the way those
are even sadder than like the Marvel
movies like when they're like oh my god
remember when eazy-e and Ice Cube met
yeah
give me a break stop pretending or when
they threw the Kardashians into the oj
thing that was a La Nina I love the
odors the Kardashians thing always gots
maybe like Kitty toe Kimmy to come over
here gimme Chloe there was the part when
I don't know if you got this far when
they're having
with David Schwimmer and he's he's like
kind of talking to them about how being
famous is not that important and okay
and then they made it a point to like
show them me like sorry I'm not
listening because I don't give a [ __ ]
that's when they jumped the shark I
think that's the last episode I so I
only missed like the last there's like
the last two or three I didn't watch
there's a jury one's really good when
you like see how dumb the jury is yeah
yeah that's racist it's crazy it's crazy
that had that happen that like this
obvious off on like a bunch of you know
smoke and mirrors and bail right
whistles and it's also funny how all
those [ __ ] are dead yeah and
his mole defense team is dead and he's
in jail yeah like they all died I mean
you know f lee Bailey was pretty old but
like they all died pretty prematurely
Johnnie Cochran died in his 50s yeah
Shapiro just died right then yeah I
think he was he was of age when he died
but yeah the one thing they said they
didn't get right is every time Shapiro
was like if we if this happens la will
riot they kept doing like that where
there is you people never said that he
was just kind of a dumb-dumb yeah I mean
he was a bleep laid by John he was
amazing everyone I liked it everyone was
like it was nothing like him I'm like
who cares it made the show better
cartoonish but great yeah I loved the
casting of everybody and I really wanted
to like every but I wanted you know but
it'd be great he was the only one that I
was like but he probably sucked but I
didn't think about it for one second
right right go Cuba dude it's so good
that you're well they were smart and
that they liked the two most important
roles Cochran and Marcia Clark were
played by the best actors yeah so
they're just like we'll have the best
actor play these two and then we'll
gimmick cast everything I like Darden
now Darden was perturbed was good yeah
he was good too
he was good I can't believe that when
that Johnnie Cochran saying and word
please was a real thing that happens
yeah that was cold
Oh Jay guys he's in jail he's I was just
talking to somebody earlier about
whether or not he's dead which he's not
yeah I see Robert Holly I've seen Robert
around
yeah I've seen Robert boy where do you
live in Hollywood I just seen him at
places but and it's a weird moment
whenever I run into Robert Blake I can't
say where I know him but I'll tell you
right after this but you know I can't
say where I know I'm from but I have
seen him I thought you'd be a big fan
I'm not a fan guy when you see Robert
Blake you're like hey I get it
hey I do this podcast and I mean look I
wouldn't he probably wouldn't say no to
it no he can't
yeah I can't say no to it Blake stole
your show idea is the one going around
picture one who took it yeah he's got a
new late-night show lake after dark I'm
not too familiar like I know he liked
what he shoot his wife or something yeah
yeah I think he had someone else do it I
forget what it is he yeah I forget I
forget the specific it's been on but
it's like everybody's like yeah yeah he
was they were at the restaurant together
or something like that and then it
happened like shortly after that I'm I'm
butchering details that we will probably
be able to cover but I mix him up with
will you with Specter a lot we realize
you have so much similar like if you
have enough money you can almost like
cuz like if I was part of that jury
I couldn't convict oj if like if the
detective was like no but I mean the
detective took evidence back to her
place I'm not say of course he did it
but I'm saying what the stuff that they
like presented this is a long way from
the other thing we're talking you were
talking about how the jury episode was
interesting and that was the best
episode for me because I I was thinking
like I probably would have done a lot of
that I would I would have at least been
like they just didn't do a convincing
enough job of yeah of convicting the guy
and that's your job in there and yeah
definitely with a lot of other people
who didn't think that they did it Plus
Naked Gun was so good yeah yeah and he's
well that people don't remember like OJ
was so beloved
like I remember when it happened like I
remember the chase and and all that cuz
I went to my friend's house to watch the
basketball game yeah and it was like
what's this it was like oh Jays being
chased and like the whole time was like
oh Jays the most gentle man like
everybody was like Nordberg no norburg
was the one who got shot instead john's
locked out maybe god damn it Shawn one
second guys I'm sorry
alright well I guess it's our podcast
now for a little bit
welcome to Danny in to be man alright
let's go to the fart cam well that's I
didn't this is my idea that uh I hope
nobody steals but I'm gonna start a new
podcast where I'm just in the stall of a
public restroom and wait for somebody to
come in and take a [ __ ] dope idea
snapchat I'll do with Pizza involved
oh we had at work it was like our head
writer it was he was like so it was
great he put because we were getting
like people who were gonna be on the
this season and then before he came in
they had fat Jew on episode 2 it's all
free we could we can't have them on no
he's fine right look he's not I was in a
movie with him what yeah I was in this
movie wiped out it was I was a cameo I
was like in two scenes I was the party
bus driver and it was fat Jew Sean
Patton well then you call it a cameo no
if they're like oh my god is that fuses
dancing
it was a weird cast that was fashion get
a st. Germain for this bus driver with
his actual bus driver good as a cameo
cause if he uses his name with camp
matches great we're gonna blow the whole
budget so you were gracing this film set
with the president what happened no it
was just a weird cast it was fat Jew me
Sean Pat and I made a joke about there's
a show Pam you gotta like actually
pissed off on Twitter about my get your
panties but it was like Sean Patton
Dustin Diamond Oh Ron Artest and the
rapper Eve I was like we were all in
this movie together I think it made a
billion dollars [ __ ] you you fat piece
of [ __ ] I mean you read things and they
kind of sound different it was called
wife doubt a wife died oh my god it was
like trying to be it was like one of
those things we was trying to beat a
hangover or whatever so what was the bus
drivers Arc I think was just like eating
like [ __ ] right there yeah it only it
just says cast Marc Maron
Oh Marc Maron's in it too yeah I forgot
about that it never come out it came out
it's on Netflix I think it's Alex now
yes oh my god no this vertex can be paid
me a couple hundred bucks I went on
Twitter or anything I was gonna watch
Philomena but now it's gonna be there Oh
what he hasn't watched tonight wiped out
her Schenectady
the Godfather trilogy or wife now
The Godfather saga or a wife down yeah
that's insane you didn't talk about this
well I was just one day of shooting I
mean they were super nice and I was the
era but I don't know if it rude I would
tell everybody about Eve when you're
they're super nice before who's the
[ __ ] I mean there was an [ __ ]
probably me but but there was a moment
where I'm like where life at you walked
in with like the huge hair and all that
but I kept end it and I'm like oh is
that like the character and then I got a
fan out oh no that's just him oh my god
Jesus this I just watched this just
talking about like weird cast members I
was up late at night and started
watching that Jack and Jill movie the
Adam Sandler movie yeah Pacino's in that
red Pacino's in it but then there's a
party scene that has well then he goes
on The Price is Right
so like Drew Carey's in it yeah and then
and then there's this party scene where
Jared from Subway Xin it a few times
well let's not compare them we all know
they're not going to heaven but very
different comparisons just not over the
air I'm not comparing them just in the
sense that like they're just so you know
like huge now like in the news for the
right boys right so like in 2012 whoo
it's like oh and by the way Billy Mays
died of cocaine yeah those guys were
really it's curious yeah I did a Billy
Mays thing for that [ __ ] world's
dumbest Oh I supposed to be Billy Mays
and they dressed me up with a bald wig
and all that then you did a cameo
he was a recurring player if there's one
thing you can't take away from Shawn
he's the email over TV that was a great
job man you guys had a great setup cuz
it was you and Chris out here just like
doing all the stuff for them it was like
you guys freaking well you just ran the
whole shift right yeah by the end it was
like because they brought in like these
like weird kind of producer guys like
UCB guys they were fine yeah I just yeah
I called the production office was like
hey can I do that kind of would shoot
down a lot of their ideas too it's like
yeah you know cuz I just kind of knew
who I was yeah right it's like like they
would send you jokes like hey try these
and I go and get what are the corny
people to do that
yeah yeah right exactly make I write my
own dick jokes yeah
but it was a great easy job I mean it
didn't pay a ton but no it's a great pay
your rent with it by the end I what do
you say by the end of it I could you
know I could more than pay my rent with
it like especially when I started doing
the producing stuff oh yeah things where
I was like cuz I've done they did like a
couple of specials in New York where
they taped it's basically the same kind
of thing and it's like huh well my
things where you just go in and you just
riff for an hour and then you and then
you're like okay I'll see ya really fun
and they're really nice people so that's
that's what makes it a lot easier so I
always wondered about being if you're on
one of these sets where the people are
[ __ ]
and you kind of wonder like you almost
not that TV of the long five appointment
it's called my dumb frenzy tells the
dumbest thing you've ever done what Dan
just did was it right now that was
pretty good
[ __ ] I didn't should've thought about it
it's alright don't worry no come back
yeah I don't know I got I mean well I
mean there's gotta be something really
bad I don't know I guess drunk drunk
drunk I mean that's what I'm thinking
it's like what's like the craziest drug
story I mean there's one
that I was in Phoenix with Stanhope when
I was like touring with him opening for
him and like I got in early like that
afternoon we were staying at like what I
was resort play every place is like a
resort
yeah Toscana when I was there yeah it's
just every hotel was like a resort he
has a pool and a [ __ ] outside bar or
whatever and so flew in got there and
and him and bingo his girlfriend never
had like hanging out by the pool having
some drinks know of a few drinks and
then I continued drinking they like kind
of took a break I'm like oh well we're
gonna go a little room and get ready and
then we'll go to the show and I just
kind of kept drinking so by show time I
was pretty [ __ ] drunk and this is the
only time I mean I've been like tipsy on
stage but like this is the only time
that I was just like hammered on stage
yeah I didn't realize how hammered I was
and I was like bombing you know yeah it
was just like I didn't realize I was
like it's them it's not me like
eventually just kind of came up was like
what it's damn I mean the stage and and
in view of everybody I thought I went to
go sit on a stool but it was a trash can
Danny's will get next episode that was
good that's really gonna hook him in for
the next one
Brett is there anything you want to pop
I think oh you know what I'm gonna go to
our mics are coming out in like a month
Mike yeah there's my podcast the bone
zone the bone zone also on all things
comedy is we're gonna be doing a live
one in New Orleans sometime in October
it's a part of a festival hell yeah
faster so yeah that's it yeah
so yeah whatever it's in October
this is the pocket yeah I think this
weekend I'll be in hyenas so check that
out I will be in New York but I have an
album out called manual-labor face and I
have a Twitter at show anytime and also
my Instagram thank you so much guys yeah
yeah nice a britannians - I'll be here
you